hi guys how are you ready yep whenever
you're ready my mask is on my earring
but
this is just real life guys because this
is the code it seems complicated
hoops are hard i i always wear hoops and
then i always get them caught
i'm not dying my hair pink today i think
cute yeah
hi i'm renee elise goldsberry and i'm
here
with paula pal and busy phillips two of
my favorite friends in the whole wide
world
and we want to hand out superlatives to
our girls five eva castmate did you guys
get senior superlatives when you were in
high school
no but i was voted funniest i always
voted most likely to be a famous actress
i think i was i feel like best physique
no i would still honestly still still
give it to you
okay most likely to bring snacks
to rehearsal i think that's me i
i would try to smuggle things in you
can't really bring food and i'd have it
and just occasionally and then i'd
always hit my mask with it so it would
bounce off because i forgot i had this
the shield on and she's always trying to
like force a bar down your throat
if you're like i'm hungry
most likely to arrive at the airport
four hours
not me not me we'll make it sarah
bareilles yes
she's timely she is that's why she's not
here she had to go to another interview
we had interviews too she cares about
but she needed to be on time
i like making most likely to do a double
take when walking by their reflection
i mean oh my god
i do feel like you and me if there was a
superlative for that in high school they
would have given me that god
but i do feel like i feel like your
looks this is why i say you
and me because i feel like our looks on
the show
are so outrageous that i would walk past
mirrors
in character and be like whoa yeah who
is shy yeah
i do that i never wearing those shoes
that made you ten feet
oh my god yeah i like you i can't
imagine that you would well i was always
excited i was very inspired by the
styling me too yeah
i mean i i got my hair like it i love it
but i but i have to tell you
i can't i mean it i could be i i don't
need to be in costume
you double take it in the mirror
sometimes i usually when i see my
reflection
best listener oh that's hard because i
feel like this
this quartet is very good at listening
and you know
if you are having a dark day which we
would have sometimes
you could come in and just be like guys
i need to talk
and everyone's like like a little
campfire yeah
very very very comfortable we're
competitive listeners
okay what is what is
um in your car you can plug in your
iphone or ipod
she's the one that always shows up
prepared to create a mood yes
yes that's true best gift giver guys it
isn't
established busy and you know what if
busy was not here
it would be you it would be you we could
all give each other candles and busy
would be like
these necklaces are all your
grandmother's teeth
and it was your favorite tooth that when
they used to kiss you
used to touch your cheek like she will
go in such a deep dive of what's
precious to you
and give you a gift that is so deeply
meaningful that that you just give up
you're like i'm just
i think it's rude i think they're both
rude i'm just going to give them
you know fragrance only loser gift
most intense starbucks order i gotta
give you guys sex i haven't even do i'm
just
i'm caffeine-free so mine's not
mine's not yeah i mean no
i mean does she share like oat milk and
stuff like it she has a little bit more
i honestly we're all really simple low
maintenance yeah
in terms of that just for low
maintenance in general yeah biggest
conspiracy
theorist not me i mean i love them but i
don't
i'm not i don't know if i believe in
them but she knows i know her
she knows them all yeah i know i know
that you i know
you guys i know someone that's the best
laughs
i don't know where it is i just leaned
in for it
athleisure wear i think that is you
really yeah you always look super cute
when you come in
in your sweats when i wear sweats i
literally look like i'm
on my way to the hospital to have
surgery you know
i'm like i look like or like i'm post-op
like i'm like it's
not my vibe and you always come in and
you look that's all i got
cute oh my god you got real cute
athleisure
even before covent i had i
most likely to randomly burst into a
song
wow you just handed it right to her
don't worry and if there was a keyboard
here
honey we'd be here all night having a
good time i do a lot of bits on the
keyboard oh my god they're good we did
it
we did it